ok ok here we go ha
Jesus that's not in the game no one's
gonna ever see that there was no ABS
Kyle's relapse Oh God lookit don't look
Vic don't like the camera I need to
clean that later I think we still need
that to shoot ok my team's ROP it's grab
a guitar no not November struggle that's
for you editor SR I'm no one's gonna
ever see if il gun yeah as you're sayin
anyway [ __ ] Jesus Christ alright and
three can do that he was a fine action
[Music]
and Mick roadkill news Mick roadkill
goodbye Bambi her mom is dead yeah and
probably hit by a car just get you a
shot yeah California legalizes eating
roadkill Lake California California so
Gavin Newsom has signed into effect the
Wildlife Traffic Safety Act which makes
it legal for drivers to take home and
eat animals they hit with their cars
according to the East Bay news even a
dog okay sorry it specifies sets up a
program that drivers who fatally injure
or or stumble upon a dead deer elk
pronghorn antelope or wild pig to remove
it as long as they registered the fine
through the state and apply for the 24
hour wildlife Salvage permits so as long
as you register with the state as part
of like their your hunting and game
license it's not like you can take
you'll still pay a fine for like hitting
it yeah it doesn't it says that there's
no fine it looks like it's just like the
drug thing where they're gonna like take
you to jail like return yourself in
pretty much no I don't think so
because it also says that it the program
will also allow drivers to report an
animal that is still living at which
point a Department of Fish and Wildlife
or a law enforcement official would be
dispatched to kill it about human yeah
[Applause]
Josh yeah so yes so I guess this is
probably an order to curb a lot of the
you know people that are hitting animals
and just like leave mile road and stuff
for like people that were you know could
potentially I mean where the people
before they were like I want to take
this home but it's something you go
maybe yeah obviously enough people to
pass thing I don't like this we're
cleaning up the earth one roadkill at a
time right there you go and you know I
mean the people in the it's vegan is it
know what died of natural causes that's
that's a vegan right getting hit by a
car is not a natural cause what's more
natural than Newton's law ok well yeah
but we could also worry about now
natural selection coming from a bullet
is awesome it's also a natural process
exactly there's a technical explanation
for what happened thus it's natural it
does cap though it doesn't count I've
asked I've asked people at Temple before
I like Buddhist temples and I was like
so you guys are totally vegan but if you
just found it out I'm gonna died on your
feet like would you eat it like it's
it's like or let it waste and they said
they would eat it because what wasting
food is worse than I like how the Asians
still give me crap I was right I don't
know I and I don't know that I would
call it vegan because I still feel like
if you gave this not use the word it
wouldn't be vegan be God to eat a piece
of meat yeah not you are so happy about
me right now I can see it can I throw
this camera so just to clarify again
though so we hit a human we can't eat
them yes
sorry ladies we call that cannibalism if
that's gonna be you're gonna be you're
[ __ ] excuse of your leg look look baby
it's not roadkill
oh god I just I pictured it smell like
roadkill and saying that's not
appetizing anymore no nope that's if you
guys have been wondering where Devin was
he's been spending last two years in the
forest just eating people
yeah entire time and he hasn't stopped
and he hasn't registered with this is
actually intervention yeah
stop yeah somebody cut it out Bobby when
people make me I wonder what
registration is like for that yeah yeah
this house guy that was way easier than
we all find I gotta bleed actually yeah
but like a man is they're crazy Ryan so
what were the what were the names on
there I mean like what were they so it's
a dead deer okay okay pronghorn antelope
or wild pig yeah those are the four that
in California uh yeah Gavin Newsom
wildlife trails down here or not inside
I think it's an East Bay news so I think
that this is more of a cow house did you
get a lot of like peacocks over your
opossums thinking about Arcadia you
trying to eat a possum you try pretty
nobody some sayings like we don't get
that type of roadkill here I think you
might like more in the mountains and
stuff like there's definitely like like
deer and stuff
hey melons you know that's actually
really smart actually I feel like having
that cuz like for what it's the bigger
ones where it's like it's something that
will guarantee damage your car right so
there's less likely to be people like
you yeah we gotta get dinner tonight
it's like oh I'm gonna be like well this
covers the con all right
mug do you know anybody cuz it like
Jesus chases animals with their car I
mean I'm not gonna say that that's not a
thing because I'm sure it's a thing
somewhere I got family Milwaukee who
will be like skunks and possums of death
with sticks I'm pretty sure I know
people who will put like today you got
the bag too huh they took out the bag I
think they're just killing it for sport
right yeah they just they killed it for
fun yeah they might be serial killer
it's just looking careful the next
family reunion yeah yeah they'd be to
death I can do it I'm when they told me
this is like a little kid I was like so
what do I go home that's what passing it
right now okay question is anyway I
don't know me as anyone here gone
hunting I'm not I'm not I do I feel like
I feel like you would go all right I fit
the trope and I haven't gone hunting
just cuz honestly even want to go
camping if you were to drive 30 minutes
to go camping is like why drive 30
minutes two minutes we are daily
metaphors okay you know do like a hiking
traveling here is about like 15 minutes
that's true yes I do I go hike so then I
go hiking you can camp on the beach -
yeah you're the most utility person I
know
no but I'm also very lazy but it's it
cuz it's like um so example for like
deer hunting and stuff like that like
it's it's a solid amount of work like if
you kill it like you need to or at least
the way I see in them all my hunter
friends is like you need to learn how to
process it cuz you can't just like
unless you have an ATV or sling that you
can't drag it back it's [ __ ] heavy
those Allah says you to drag some guns
he could do it that's look at forgot
honest talking mr. macho man or a
sandbag toss and all that [ __ ] man let's
go no that dude yeah one of them he's a
sound operator okay Kyle's got like the
guns going with he's gonna boom that
dude
I like dragging it behind me a cow's
just like do an overhead press it's just
another obstacle yeah he drops it off
easy I'll meet you back home and runs
the 15 miles back it would be nothing
compared to smartness but yeah I mean
you need to learn how to process it and
like skin it and like you know cut the
meat out and stuff like that in it's
just a lot of stuff that I would like to
learn I feel like it's important skill
to know how to do but ultimately I just
have not set aside the time for it coz
I've been invited before I've been I
have friends to go to Texas to do that
kind of stuff what I do want to do is
aerial hog hunting though in Texas you
in a hut copter and you're just like
trying to find him and just yeah okay so
did too many hunters for context she's a
feral hog problem in Texas is it's scary
like feral hogs I don't know if you've
seen one or seen what they do to like
cattle and other dogs and stuff like
that Oh dig or walk them off like and
it's dangerous they spread disease get
into anything so I'm hearing about them
you know they killed Robert Baratheon
wait what
Game of Thrones Game of Thrones
like a couple of minutes okay so I've
seen the woman when she's naked walking
the streets because you're saying that
earlier today no no first I've seen the
first of all minutes of Game of Thrones
and I saw the last couple minutes of
season seven wait to use you saw you
lying exactly to the things I've seen is
a kid getting thrown out of the [ __ ]
tower okay and then conveniently leaving
out the anal sex beforehand and I see
the kid is able to look into the future
past and present oh so you just came for
the brand scenes that's me that's a
weird that's all I'm seeing why that's
just my life I'm pornhub and while
watching the SEC things you happen to
watch all the porn you choose Cersei
over Daenerys yeah well my friends in
Texas can vouch for this yeah they they
[ __ ] up the land because they go in
there digging for food so then they mess
up all the farmland and stuff they hurt
people they hurt animals and they hurt
livestock so because of that you can go
they have companies that will go and
trap hogs and shoot hogs because it's
open season you can literally just go
and shoot as many as you want and then
they also offer these helicopter aerial
and aerial gun runs where you get into a
helicopter and then the farmers pay they
pay the company that does the helicopter
stuff and then you pay the company to go
up in the helicopter to go shoot it hogs
because there's literally just so many
yeah yeah they need to kill as many as
well w so it's a complicated story like
if you actually like look at it it's
it's the problem with like capitalism is
yes and it's good and bad right like
you're like yeah all these people are
coming out to kill these hogs now but
they're nuts and I'm their interests
that want to keep the hot air so that
you can keep the business going so he's
just saying it's complicated because
from what I've heard there's so many
hogs is yeah the problem is so many but
that they're bringing all this business
to do it now but but because of that at
the same time think about it if now
you're making a million dollars eight
years to fly people up you don't want
all of the hogs to go away sure so I'm
here
I'd be let them reproduce you trying to
manipulate the system vertically and try
to like create more hogs make them breed
more so there's more I'd be curious to
see how like if that's a real thing like
if they're like curbing it cuz as far as
I know there are so many that they just
don't know what to do it to the point
where they're literally setting up
tannerite traps and they're waiting for
all the hogs to go tanner a traps
explosive expose so they wait until the
slugs get close enough and they make
this explosive and they blow up like 50
hogs experimented with different ways to
give it killing you set out like poison
yeah poison is gonna comment that
poisons bad though bullies goes down the
food chain that's the problem like
there's a bunch of different methods
that they use so it's a yeah so they
aerial gunning is pretty popular because
it's not it doesn't like leave any boys
but it's fun I'm imagining a whole movie
scene they just get in already
well this thing's for the Queens and
choosing them all pretty much that like
you see video is just like wow this is
like it's like yeah that's because I'm
having the good ryan's rises so they're
like with a sniper rifle shoots to
tannerite so yeah so you just see like
the explosion in his eyes I think we're
coming up with the skit and everything I
want to comment below if you want to see
one of these kids come to life yes it
happen
but see like it'll be fun up until like
one of us Falls and then also I'm like
one of the hogs picks up the rifle and
they're like hogs strung together with
these three heads shooting everybody
it's like rise to the planets with the
rights of the feral hog mr. president we
have a problem with
[Music]